wir wollen jetzt allerdings mal auf eine
ganz aktuelle rede vom ukrainischen
präsidenten wolodimir selensky schauen
der hat sich nämlich mit einem
dramatischen appell an das belarussische
volk gewendet
er sagte unter anderem aus eurem land
kommen russische streitkräfte zu uns und
die ukraine wurde mit raketen
bombardiert
aus eurem land findet man unsere kinder
zerstört unsere häuser sowie lenski
weiter sie versuchen alles in die luft
zu jagen was seit jahrzehnten von
unseren vätern und großeltern aufgebaut
wurde sie entscheiden wer ihr seid dass
sie ihr sein wollt wie werdet ihr die
kinder in den kindern in die augen
schauen wie werdet ihr einander noch in
die augen schauen fragt sie lenski
werdet ihr eure nachbarn begegnen wie
sind eure nachbarn wir sind ukraine und
wir sind und bleiben eure nachbarn ihr
seid velaros und ihr seid nicht russland
sagt er auch wenn es aus eurem land
keine aggressionen geben würde dann
wären wir in minsk und könnten einen
dialog führen als ihr noch neutral wat
da haben wir uns in minsk öfter
getroffen und dialoge geführt jetzt
haben wir eine wichtige entscheidung
gesehen diese entscheidung liegt jetzt
vor und jetzt ist es abhängig also vom
belarussischen volk meint er nicht von
russland nicht von der ukraine nicht von
den usa sondern vom belarussischen voll
klar sind wir für ein gespräch bereits
aktuellen ski auch wir möchten dass der
krieg ein ende hat ich habe mehrere
städte vorgeschlagen für einen dialog in
jedem land aus welchem keine raketen
fliegen das wäre ihnen dann recht ich
wünsche mir aufrichtig dass belarus
wieder so gut und sicher wird wie es
alle vor nicht allzu langer zeit gesehen
haben die richtige wahl zu treffen ihr
habt das sehr wohl die wichtigste wahl
ihres lebens sosinski weiter